you hear me sound good so it's the magic
hour of 1130 I'm Dion chase a graduate
student here at ohsu and it's my
pleasure to introduce to you Gary olsem
Gary is a Donald brand distinguished
professor of informatics a UC Irvine and
he's also a professor emeritus from
Michigan his doctorate originally was in
psychology from Stanford we will hold
out against ever he's a fellow of the
Association for Computing Machinery the
Association for psychology the American
Psychological Association member of the
Chi Academy in winner of the Lifetime
Achievement Award for computer human
interaction he's a member of the
editorial board of nine significant
journals so be nice to if you want to
publish in this area and it is
consultant to literally a score of
others his list of grants spans three
pages his list of publications takes an
additional 10 I'm not going to go into
that in more detail but I know he's not
patting it because he hasn't listed to
the three on Swiss railroads they're not
out there either so he's got a wide
range of interests he's very
accomplished as a researcher as an
administrator he's been the interim dean
of the School of Informatics in an
administrator learning project teams in
grants so he actually has have
experienced all these areas he's
considered he is a leading thinker in
both cognitive science and human
computer interaction especially as it
applies to computer-supported
collaborative work
and he's the type of person that Google
comes to in Google sense we've got some
money what do you want to do good and
he's a good person to be around I
actually met him and his wife Judy last
winter when I went to the
computer-supported collaborative work
conference up in Seattle and I heard a
presentation what they're doing and I
said this is a person I've got to have
on my committee and I'm very lucky and
very proud that he's doing he gave us a
choice of topics today and the fowls
voted and what we decided we'd like to
hear him talk about was basically an
overview of the work they've been doing
over the last several decades on how
people work together over distance on an
administrative note if you have a good
question for Gary this is being
videotaped and disseminated live so
please push the button in front of you
will you ask a question as normal and
Gary we're delighted to hear you and I'm
looking forward to your talk thanks much
I'm going talk about working together a
part that's kind of the latest turn of
phrase we're using for this body of work
and as deion said that it spans are we
back into the early to mid-1980s we've
been working on this topic I'm going to
use the word we a lot because the work
itself is highly collaborative my wife
Judy and I have been working together
ever since we got married 30 years ago
but these are Steve Abrams and Matt
beats her a couple of postdocs who had
worked with us recently Julia Haynes as
a PhD student jingwen got her master's
degree at the university Minnesota has
now a full-time research associate in
our lab and we've had a large s of
financial support for this work as well
over the years actually probably our
principal supporter over the whole time
period of say twenty five years been the
National Science Foundation the thing we
worked on most recently is something we
call the collaboration success wizard
which
is an online tool to assess how your
collaboration is going and give you
feedback so I'm going to talk about the
work that underlies it and come back and
talk about the wizard itself so this is
I'm kind of using the wizard is the
frame for this talk it's turned out to
be a useful tool it tells you where is
where things in your project are strong
what you might be vulnerable to and what
to do about it and I'll give you some
examples later when I talk more about it
in a little detail the wizard is based
on a lot of work as I say we've had more
than 20 years of research mostly on
scientific collaboration I guess that
reflects the fact that a lot of our
funding has come from the National
Science Foundation but we also have
studied business collaborations Judy at
Michigan was in the business school and
she now actually has an honorary
appointment in the business school at
her vine and so we had access to a
number of businesses the do long
distance collaboration and we've done a
lot of work we've collected a lot of
data over the years and we've done a lot
of work on what seems what factors seem
to differentiate successful from
unsuccessful collaborations and so
that's the kind of the primary database
that's now quite enormous we did a kind
of a summary of this work back in the
late 90s published this paper in the
year 2000 called distance matters and it
is it was kind of a summary of what we
thought things were at that point in
time more recently we put out a book on
the work we've done on scientific
collaboration and chapter four in this
book is sort of an update of what we'd
wrote back in two thousand and we've
changed our ideas a little bit because
things have apple we learned some new
things the book also has a lot of case
studies about specific projects that we
look at in some detail we're working on
another book this one we hope to finish
in the next month or so it's called
working together apart it's part of a
series put out by Morgan and claypoole
this is a publishing firm it's a
subsidiary of Morgan
wolfman and they published what they
call synthesis lectures on race topics
mostly in science and engineering and
they do have one in what they call a
human-centered informatics and so we've
got a contract with them to put this
monograph out and it'll bring the story
yet further up to date because we've
learned some things even since the 2008
book developing our ideas here has come
from several sources one is a kind of an
empirical part which is we've gathered
enormous amount of data both in breadth
and in depth and we've a lot of effort
into looking at sort of what
differentiates successful from
unsuccessful collaboration but of course
we've also mind the literature as well
there's by now a huge literature a lot
of people are interested in this topic a
large literature in and turns out in a
number of different domains not just in
the cscw world but in the business
literature in the communication studies
literature and so on and one little
frustration is a lot of these
literatures are kind of disjoint they
don't cite each other and so on so it's
a little bit tricky to go and try to
find all the things that are relevant
but there's a lot known out there and so
we have a kind of a rich empirical base
both from our own work and from the work
of others to come up with these ideas
are our empirical partners had sort of
two strategies one is kind of a breadth
strategy we have a database of projects
mostly in scientific collaboration
although even recently there's been an
emergence of long-distance technology
media collaboration in the humanities
which is kind of an interesting
development and we're kind of looking at
that especially right now but our
database has more than 750 examples of
projects so it's and it just grows I
mean when we moved to irvine in 19 in
2008 our database had about 250 projects
in it we hired a postdoc just to do the
update of the database and she was able
to find another five of five hundred
project so it's just a growing area and
I think this is I think it's come to the
point in time we're working with people
who aren't in your physical location is
just a normal activity now it's still
not easy as I'll point out but it's
can become very common so for the one
goal is for each of the 750 projects get
a little bit of information about what
happened mine websites publications
things like that but of course
especially when you're talking about
projects it didn't work out people tend
not to self disclose that so we've had
to do some kind of more in-depth work so
we've here's just shows you the we have
a database that's online here's the URL
and this is just a snapshot of the first
part of the letter A in that database
and a database has both a public in a
private part the public part has a lot
of kind of general information when
we've gone and done detailed interviews
and observations that's in the private
part of this database and we have to
discuss with the people what the
conditions would be for access to that
here's just an example of a particular
project of biomedical informatics
research Network which is one of the
particularly interesting ones that we
looked at in some depth so it to
complement this kind of bread thing
we've done in-depth studies of the
number of projects kind of an alphabet
soup of projects something that we were
involved directly in so for example this
opera atmospheric research collaborators
one we did at Michigan where we had a
decade of funding from NSF to do that
one similarly with the Great Lakes the
center for age research Michigan was one
of the Big Ten universities involved in
that we were having evolved in the nice
project on earthquake engineering but
others we had contacts with and were
able to kind of go and find out in more
detail what actually really happened
with these projects and when I mentioned
that in the 2008 book there are case
studies almost all of these are written
up as case studies in that volume if
you're interested in more details what
any of them so here are some examples of
project we were involved in we actually
were involved not just studying that we
have who are building the software for
them so in the upper atmospheric physics
project we built all the software over
over the period of a decade and
similarly with the nice project north
coke engineering east during the first
three or four years we were working
collaboratively with the National Center
for
supercomputing applications to build
applications for that so here's how I'm
going to do a kind of a quick overview
of what we call the theory of remote
scientific collaboration actually
calling it a theory was Judy's idea and
I don't mean that apologetically I think
it's sort of a Morissette of working
hypotheses rather than a fully formed
theory but theory I guess is a kind of a
more attractive or attention-getting
term so we've kind of grouped our ideas
about what what matters into five broad
categories the nature of the work common
ground collaboration readiness things
how to do with management and
decision-making and technology readiness
each of those in turn has a lot of
structure embedded in them so that if
you the collaboration success wizard
which I introduced briefly to tap these
topics has on the order of 50 ish
questions in in the online survey so
there's a lot of sub sub points to all
of this so let me just quickly kind of
go through each of these things by the
way if you have questions as I go along
I'm happy to feel field questions on the
fly nature of the work has to do with
what is it you're doing and turns out
that work various quite widely and the
kind of work that's relatively easy to
do when you're geographically
distributed is work that is easily
divided up so you can assign
responsibility for different parts of
the project to different people involved
in the project obviously you don't want
total independence because it's got it's
a collaboration you want to have some
some way of putting these pieces
together and so on similarly you want to
make sure that you don't drift apart in
terms of kind of the overriding vision
of the project and so on but we've seen
examples particularly in business where
they've tried to take really hard
problems and and have them done
geographically distributed that there's
a lot of trouble so what you're doing
matters a lot common ground has to do
with what the participants share in
terms of their knowledge their
experience with working with
each other their vocabulary a kind of a
common way of going about work and we've
seen some projects that had kind of some
early struggles which put a lot of
energy into this talk this this matter
dumb of particular biomedical project we
studied that was headquartered at
Columbia they spent a year building a
dictionary because it turns out it's my
experience with the biomedical world is
the terminology is not common there's a
lot of disagreement as to what you call
things and it's important to get those
kinds of things straightened out this
bioinformatics research Network which
focused well the part that we studied
most in most detail focused on gathering
MRIs from schizophrenic patients from
about 20 research centers again they
thought a lot of time into developing an
ontology so they knew they were all
talking about in terms of brain
structure brain function and so on so
that's an important part collaboration
readiness is I think especially
interesting and tricky one because
question is why are you working together
and there are 10 draw three lots of
reasons I mean go a good reason to work
together is because you've had success
working together in the past fact Sarah
Keith learn Jonathan Cummings published
paper recently that looked at a whole
series of National Science Foundation
projects and they found that was a
really key factor in whether your future
collaborations were successful that you
built on past successful ones so that's
important but people collaborate for all
kinds of reasons again I kind of a good
reason is that you need a bigger
constellation of specialty sort of
expertise but you know if you don't have
the right expertise in your own
organization you have to go find it you
may be looking for people you don't know
very well we have different kinds of
backgrounds different kinds of work
styles and so on that can be tricky
probably the most risky reason for
working together is because funders say
you have to there's more and more a
culture these days in the funding
organizations to require or reward a
collaborative work collaborative
research and in fact certainly in the in
the in the European Union they have
really complicated collaborations they
force you to put together because they
want to make sure that
the most prosperous members of the
European Union are working with their
colleagues in the leet less prosperous
countries and so you have to put
together a big project you have to have
representation from different parts of
the European Union well those are very
risky because if you're trying to get
the money if you want to get the money
and you're trying to get it by putting
the other a team and off on a team that
you worry don't know the participants
extremely well it can be very very
tricky and so that's one you know
mandate from the funder is kind of a
risky one we've told this to funders and
they're they're aware of that and of
course they're very interested in our
story about what makes things work and
we've given this presentation to both
NSF and NIH to program managers and
they're extremely interested in these
ideas as ways of thinking about how to
help encourage successful collaborations
among people putting the proposals in
kind of another component of
collaboration readiness is how much you
trust your colleagues are you you are
you confident that when they say they're
going to do something they will do it
I'll do it right will things like
decisions about how to allocate
resources be done with everybody's best
interests that's a really tricky one and
some of the work we've done recently
with the wizard that's one of the
factors at the surface the most often is
while I'm not sure that the project
leadership value is what I do enough to
give me some resources and that's a
really tricky issue are the goals
aligned is there when it is order
everyone at seeking more that's the same
thing often that's not the case those
are often very different and there's a
concept that's come out of the
psychological literature called group
self-efficacy el bandura a psychologist
develop the idea of individuals
self-efficacy the whole idea that you
feel as though you're capable of doing
something and Jack Carroll who's at Penn
State and been in this field for a long
time so reusable came up the idea of a
core of the group counterpart of this is
the group feel like it can accomplish
things and this is turning out to be a
quite interesting concept to look at
this is about management again in a
survey of something like 500 projects at
the National Science Foundation Sarah
keesler and Jonathan Cummings
came up with I think to kind of
interesting conclusions first they found
that in this large collection of
projects mostly done in the in the first
decade of the 21st century we actually
had several in that pot that projects
where most of the principles were
co-located were on average more
successful than projects where they were
not co-located that's the kind of
distance matter story but what they
found in the subset that were not
co-located the ones that had some
success were the ones that had the best
management or manage the best and that
actually kind of affirms things we've
seen in our similar case studies where
there was a two projects in higher Jenny
physics that we looked at where one of
them was directed initially by a
computer scientist the second one was
directed black a energy physicist and in
the first year or so of those projects
they were having a lot of trouble well
they got some advice and they actually
each project went out and hired an MBA
to help manage you quite large
complicated projects multi-million
dollar projects well these were people
that had some business experience with
managing teams and turn these projects
around now both scientists and funders
kind of shy away from the idea of
acquiring expensive business consultants
for the research projects but I think
there's a kind of a growing awareness
that it works and so certainly for very
large projects this kind of budget line
ends up making a lot of sense because
you need somebody who has both the
knowledge and the time to really kind of
pay attention these kinds of things so
how things work is really how things are
managed is really critical a good
project manager that seems to be a
factor that looms sniffling a lot of the
things we've looked at good
communication plans that is are you
regularly in touch with people it's real
easy you know out of sight out of mind
is real easy to forget about the people
who wander your location and we find
especially projects where there's kind
of a major cluster and then a series of
satellites sometimes the satellites even
have there's one person those satellites
feel very disconnected from the project
and it really takes a lot of effort on
the part of
project leadership to make sure they're
included make sure you know what they're
doing and so on a real area of problem
problem our decisions made Fairly
nothing you know by the people more than
feeling like they're being screwed
because all the money is going to you
know the leadership of the project or
something like that another kind of
tricky issue is time zone differences
overlap in your work days and so on and
give a whole talk on that one because
we've actually been looking at that
we're doing some work now with Google
looking at collaborative projects in the
Pacific Rim where the participants are
either in India China or in the United
States and just unbelievably complicated
issues with both culture and with
managing time zone differences illegal
and financial issues we looked at a very
large project in our medical school and
there was some real serious concerns
about intellectual property matters that
had been overlooked by the project
leadership and so on so as I say there's
lots of kind of detailing in uncut in it
unpacking each of these ideas a
technical readiness has to do with
several things you know so what's the
technical sophistication of the people
who are working and since we've been
working this area for two and a half
decades that's changed enormously I mean
when we started some projects back at
around nineteen ninety a lot of the
people involved were just barely
starting to use email and we're
uncomfortable with it and so on you
don't see that today although again
we've seen in some biomedical project
some of the highest level people are
kind of anti keyboard anti computer and
their attitudes we've still seen people
who have their secretaries print out
their email on paper and then they write
comments on in the secretaries type of
back in but that's getting rare and rare
and rare people are pretty comfortable
with things like email some forms of
conferencing and so on though again
we've it in the recent working on with
the wizard we have a whole section on
what technologies people are using and
sort of to our surprise um widespread
use of email
widespread use of audio conferencing
some use of video conferencing but lots
of things that are out there blogs
wiki's ways of sharing screen now the
application on your screen sort of more
sophisticated awareness tools shared
calendars and so on are still not very
widely used at least in the projects
that we've been looking at so there
still is kind of enormous opportunity
because a lot of these tools are really
very powerful when you look at a
sophisticated organization like Google
where you know they have young really
technically savvy people they're making
very effective use of a wide range of
these kinds of tools and our colleague
Jonathan Gruden at Microsoft did some
surveys at Microsoft as well and found
similar kinds of things so there are
some me know powerful opportunities here
and the question is how people get
comfortable with them and also some
things happening the we just we just
gotta just published a paper I just got
accepted it will appear at the Chi
conferences spring on cloud computing so
if you are familiar with things like
Dropbox or Google Apps the the model
that is being proposed there is that you
all everything you're working with is in
the cloud wherever that the cloud is and
we have found in interviews with people
that mostly at university is so far
enormous confusion about the cloud what
is it where is it where is my stuff and
people are surprised by things that
happen even Judy was using google docs
for her class last year and we've gotten
permission to use some of the lat mature
for a research project we're doing with
Google and suddenly these docs are
disappearing and we needed a revision
history because we were studying how
they got revised over time and they
started disappearing and nobody knew why
so I said that's an example of kind of
mysteries in the cloud some interesting
work with virtual worlds we have
colleagues at Irvine who are studying
the role of virtual world technology for
supporting software engineering awesome
interesting opportunities there also
another part of technical readiness is
is the technical
support up to snuff because you still
even for things like email you still
have trouble if you soften you need
somebody you can call on for help and
often often the technical help is very
unevenly distributed across some of
these projects and of course if there's
if you're collecting data in many
different sites they're quite quickly it
to be issues about standardization data
data standards data sharing and so on a
lot of the art scientific projects are
wonderful you share remote instruments
the project we did an opera atmospheric
research focused on a community that was
using a suite of physical facilities up
in Greenland and in the course of
project those all put on the internet so
they could use do real-time data
acquisition about things in the upper
atmosphere for things that we're opening
up in Greenland well a lot of issues
about how you manage remote instruments
there are safety issues for certain
kinds of instruments for one of the
instance there was a big incoherent
scatter radar that was about 20 meters
across and you didn't want steering a
thing around from California if some
guys up there maintaining it you had to
have a lot of information about some of
these safety issues so they say there's
a wide range of factors and actually I
mean an example of a factor that we sort
of insufficiently considered in the past
that we're now kind of beating to think
a lot more about is some of the
characteristics of the individuals
involved what their kind of
psychological cognitive profiles are and
so on and that's kind of another wrinkle
in all of this about how collaboration
works and that's when we're kind of
ready to get our head around right now
the cut so you can say well there's an
enormous range of things that could go
wrong and the answer is yes it's a story
those of us who study collaboration
certainly 10 or 15 years ago the story
was the success rate for collaborations
beyond two or three people is very low
actually where some figures akkad about
15 years ago that said that only like
one in three these collaborations
succeeds by any sort of reasonable
measure of success and I would submit
that putting distance into the equation
lowers those odds even more now I think
that's chain
changed some because we've learned a lot
of stuff and just some examples of
things that are give us a little bit of
optimism you know we made a lot of tools
we've made a lot of it development
advances in the last decade or a decade
and a half on you know sweets of tools
for managing knowledge things like
Google Docs and Dropbox and with Jesus
on a better awareness support the whole
world of social computing as providing
some really interesting opportunities
people are become more sophisticated
about project management and how to kind
of manage a project over space and time
tricky tricky set of issues we've helped
a better understanding of incentives how
you guys to get align incentives to get
success and of course a lot of stuff
having the trust building log that stuff
comes out of the business world but ends
up being quite important I mean the
interesting little tidbit here is
colleague of ours he was a postdoc in
our lab and I was at Carnegie Mellon and
he's a study software engineering and he
was studying some projects where they
were building telecommunication software
with sites in three sites in the u.s.
cited in the UK France and Germany and
they just thought they and they were you
they were actually using things like
video conferencing to help make the
white light work well there was an
attitude at least the time they're doing
a project that video conferencing was
kind of you know expensive and special
and so you would wait for everybody to
get get there and then you turn it on
have your meeting and then turn it off
well turns out a lot of studies by
organizational scientists have found
that the stuff that happens as you
gather for a meeting and the stuff that
happens as you break up and walk away
all the kind of informal chatting and so
on is really really really important
well these people who are doing video
conferencing were you know thinking that
oh it was it's a waste of time presses
it and talk about soccer or something in
all over the conference so we should
only talk about the work well what Jim
burps had found was that that was a real
big big mistake that the parts of the
projects he was looking at that we're
working
r 1 square people did have informal
chitchat with their colleagues all over
overseas you know talking to your
friends in Germany or France about
what's going on what their holidays are
what's happening with their families and
so on those kinds of things build up the
kind of social glue and trust and
respect that make projects look better
so that kind of stuff is really
important the section in book stores now
devoted to how to manage virtual teams
just keeps growing and growing and
growing because people are making a lot
of money on other at least some of them
are but it's I think it reflects the
fact that we just we now know a lot and
it takes effort it helps to know how to
make these things work and it takes
effort to do it it's that you don't get
it for free but we now know a lot and so
there are there are ways of figuring out
what you need to do to make this stuff
work and we hope that our book will be
kind of added to that scene um in terms
of things like culture and so on there's
a lot of valuable resources out there
there's this book series called culture
shock I don't know if any of you are
familiar with it it's written by people
who are from a different culture and
write about what they experienced in a
culture so like what about Germany
somebody from I think that one's talked
about somebody from the US talks about
what well if you look what they learn
about living in Germany and so on what
was the interesting one for us was the
one about the u.s. written by somebody
who didn't live in the US and all the
things they saw when they came there's a
company based in San Francisco that we
are working with called globe smart
aperion is actually the name of the
company but their product is called
globe smart it's an online assessment
tool for measuring cultural factors and
the it's actually a very empirically
based project they they just went
through a revision cycle from version
extraversion why I don't remember what
the numbers were but in between they had
administered this to 400,000 people so
they had this enormous database of
findings about how people very done a
bunch of dimensions and their assumption
is that obviously people in within a
single culture can be quite varied
there's a whole distribution of kindness
Americans and Swift's and so on and what
they do is they they measure your your
individual profile and then measure the
profiles of other members of your team
and you see see what where why some of
the disconnects and what you could do
about them and they have the kind of
like our wizard when they discover
disconnects among the participants they
have some ideas about things you can do
to ameliorate those differences Julia
Haynes who works in our lab they're
actually using globe smart in some
laboratory studies she's doing of a
multicultural collaboration story Irvine
is a very multicultural campus we have
students mostly from the Pacific Rim but
from many different cultural backgrounds
and so she's putting together teams who
are doing a task in the laboratory she
measures their gold smart profiles
before they take part in the study
learning some very interesting things
about that time zones I think times
older I mean if this is an example of
something is never going to go away and
you know people talk about well so I can
work from me know before in the
afternoon until midnight so I am in
better sync with my colleagues there's
been a lot of resistance to that idea I
figure which company was Intel or some
company where they had sites i think it
was in tell cuz they have their local
right there in hillsboro and then they
have a site in the bay area and they
have a site in either bangalore or one
of the places in india and they got
enormous resistance from from their
indian colleagues to shifting their work
days because they said we have families
we have lives and we're not going to
shift our work day just to make it
easier for you guys on the west coast
and get your work done so it's a tricky
issue that you know things that seem
like potential solutions are sort of
socially awkward but we're there's sort
of emerging sort of better tools to
support what I call a synchronous
awareness being aware of what your
colleagues did when they were working
and that's an area that we're
particularly interested in ourselves
because these kind of really super long
distance collaborations are getting more
and more and more common especially in
the in the corporate world but I still
argue thats about all these advances
it's really hard
and it was a we opened this are you the
opener end this this paper on distance
matters with an anecdote there was a
book published a while ago called the
death of distance and we've argued over
and over and over again it's like Mark
Twain's thing a lot you know the rumors
of my death have are somewhat premature
we think that's the true of distance as
well that distance is a serious problem
and it'll be there forever in some form
okay with that as kind of the back of
background as to what the material is
we're talking about let me talk a little
bit now about the the wizard itself
first of all any questions about the
story so far yeah
ok
mm-hmm turns out i had offered a couple
of other topics to talk about and
another one is we're doing a big project
with google studying the rollout of
google apps on university campuses we're
looking currently looking at five UC
campuses plus the University of Michigan
where we have strong contacts these are
all universities that have made their
like umich.edu address on email accounts
is now a google gmail account and so
with using that email address you've
inherited all the Google stuff and what
we're doing is we're surveying we do an
annual survey of students we've surveyed
about 120 students on each of these six
campuses and we've done interviews with
faculty and graduate students we've done
interviews with administrators
responsible for the decision to make to
adopt this infrastructure and you know
in many cases the reason for adopting
google apps as your campus
infrastructure is cost because what
you're doing is you're basically
outsourcing the support rather than
having to keep all your versions up to
date and so on through your own IT
people they just happen out there in the
cloud I mean I know if you're a frequent
user may in itself it can be kind of
disconcerting one day i'll log into
gmail the interface is all different and
you were never told about this and
things you could find easily you can't
find now and so on and then there's this
cloud issue and that the whole story I
told you about the cloud problems comes
from that work that in our interviews
with people students and faculty and
staff we found that there is a lot of
confusion about that it's furthermore
the case that there is a security
concern and on no campus has the medical
school adopted this so the UCI medical
school is not part of this and so on
because they're just concerned about
security issues we're actually going to
do a project with the city of Los
Angeles because they were considering
adopting Google
apps but not only were their social
service departments unwilling to but the
police department the fire department
someone were unwilling to be part of it
and so that whole thing project fell
through so there are some really serious
security issues with this and I think
people are still very confused about how
things are working and you know part of
the reason we're doing this with
Google's financial support is to give
them some feedback but you know what is
it about all the stuff that's bothering
people and confusing people and so on
and the good thing is they are listening
to us they've actually made some changes
in some of their software based on our
findings so we may make some progress
but I think this whole thing about it's
just funny trade-off that you know
there's the mood to sort of more
openness and sharing and collaboration
and so on kind of goes against the grain
of security and privacy and control and
it's just it's a really complicated
issue and I think we're it's very much a
work in progress very much a work in
progress so we're not the first people
to think about measuring collaboration
iBM has a collaboration assessment tool
that sort of focuses at the
organizational level there's a thing
called the collaboration consortium that
there's a kind of consortium of
companies cisco is one of the leaders of
that consortium we've actually worked a
lot with that collaboration consortium
including measuring their collaboration
which isn't kind of fun so the idea of
kind of quite figure out some way of
assessing what's going on so either to
understand or to provide feedback or
Corrections and so on it's kind of in
there these days and of course you're
working on it as well in a particular
clinical domain so the wizard grew out
of our work mostly on scientific
collaboration and it's we've taken our
ideas and manifested in a series of
questions we went through all the
development process of making sure you
know sitting with respondents as her
answering questions so they could
explain when they didn't understand
things and so on because you know when
you do an interview if somebody is
puzzled by your question you can
rephrase it and so on
someone's taking an online survey you're
not there anymore so we did a lot of
sort of iterative development to the
point where they could be understood and
then you know we put all kinds of
questions that they answer questions
have either scales or response choices
but for every single question in the
wizard we have a free text box if they
want to make any additional comments and
it's turned out that's been very useful
for us it's been a way of well evolving
the wizard over time and we'll also
learn some interesting things we didn't
think to ask about at the end if you
take the wizard it takes you about 20
minutes or so to do the whole thing you
are offered a report and it says based
on your responses your project looks
like this and it says here are some good
things that are working well here's some
things that are troublesome and for the
troublesome things here are some things
you could do about it all that is based
on research either ours or those stuff
we draw out the literature if we do a
project and our strategy has been to do
a project we've done 12 projects so far
involving 200 respondents and the
biggest one was about 40 respondents on
one project the smallest one I think was
like five or six and what we do is we
sort of manually put together a project
based report to the project leadership
and that's going to be very interesting
so we go through all the different
responses both the quantitative
responses and all these free texts
things and come up with what we saw
going on and then give them particularly
a written report or in some case we've
been willing to show up at a leadership
meeting and give them a verbal report as
well and again the idea is to give them
some feedback about how things are going
the this just get sort of a screen dump
here's what a question looks like here's
kind of what up a the beginning of a
report looks like we have three versions
so far first of all they're always
focuses on a project now we've
encountered people have come to us with
organizations that are more what I would
consorcio that they are a ways of kind
of facilitating many projects and we're
having the process of evolving or you're
designing a new version of the wizard
that focuses more on that kind of thing
as opposed to a specific project but
right now it focus on a specific project
you're working on some problem some
number of people over some time period
what is the other projects been finished
in that case the wizard can serve as
kind of a data collection device there
was a Superfund research project or a
super-fun project that was I think
headquartered arizona state that we did
that with there's a second version of
the wizard which focuses on project
that's currently ongoing we've done a
number of them on that area and the idea
is that you're in the middle of your
project maybe you could could benefit
from some you know mid-course feedback
and corrections and so on and one that
we even kind of enjoyed a lot is one
which our future or planned projects
that you have a group that are going to
our about to submit a proposal to some
organization and you'd like to know what
you're doing the fruit the very first
one of these we did was at UCI they were
going after one of these translational
science centers at NIH and they actually
had tried several times before and it
got scores that were close but they
didn't get funded and so they learned
about shortly after we moved to irvine
and we worked with them they're the ones
that we we we describe what we want what
we do they put together they give us a
list of 70 potential participants in
their center of those 70 40 filled the
wizard out so we had to read which
database about what happened they are we
gave us a very good feedback both
positive and negative they in the
proposal to NIH wrote these experts on
collaboration assess us and here's what
they learn here are some strong points
about our project in some areas of
concern and for the areas of concern
here's what we're going to do about them
well he got funded now I don't think we
were the sole reason for it but it's
kind of fun to think we may
looky neat effect on it anyway they got
funded about a year and a half into
their or senator now so we're just about
to go and do a a present version of the
assessment with that Center because we
they've had some time to get going and
we're going to see to what extent issues
we flagged in the proposal stage
actually mattered then in the in the
operation of the center and so for
lobbies project we'd like to like to
assess the more than once we get a sense
of how things are unfolding over time
just this last summer there were two
groups that were putting together
Science and Technology Center proposals
to NS cell and ass effing we did them
both the center now dealing they're not
on this list yet anyway that was a very
interesting exercise and again they put
in their proposals that they'd had gone
through this assessment and so on so
we're actually working a lot with
different kinds of groups about this
what have we learned well we're kind of
in the midst that we have as I think we
have data from about 200 respondents on
12 different projects and so we're in
the midst of trying to do some more
quantitative analysis of all the
quantitative information of course we
also have all the free text comments and
actually we find that when people say i
don't know about something that we think
it may be a critical piece of a
collaboration we find that kind of
interesting and they're kind of
surprisingly informative so we're in the
middle of doing a lot of this more
detailed work on this very large
database we've created here's a couple
of testimonials the collaboration
consortium which was a midterm
assessment talked about how it actually
helped them make some changes for year
three in their project and this nano
structures for electrical energy storage
again felt like they had learned some
things about their project that allow
them to make some changes and how they
were going to run in subsequent years we
actually find that even without our
reports people people report to us that
just taking the wizard sensitizes them
to the issues that are going on I never
thought to ask that question they would
say things like that
so it's actually just a helpful device
as a kind of way of increasing your
awareness of kind of the issues you
should be thinking about um where you
know as a favor is just beginning some
quantitative analysis of all this and
you know there's lots of issues there's
lots of covariation and their responses
and so on way so I give you a couple of
examples of some preliminary things
we've seen the one of the questions we
asked them kind of late is you know and
again it's phrased differently depending
on whether it's a past present or future
project but these are self-reported
measures of success lots of ways to
measure success but that's one you know
do you think your project is successful
do you think it will be successful if
it's a future project and so on and we
found that some aspects of collaboration
readiness correlate significantly with
that success measure having a common
ground nature of the work less so so it
suggests that people often ask us of
these very these five sets of factors
which are the most important well this
is the goal of this phase is to get an
answer to that and lisa is a suggestion
here that something like collaboration
readiness and common ground are maybe
more important than the nature of the
work that's very tentative one and get
some pretty significant correlations
with management and planning issues and
I mentioned there's already a fair
amount of evidence that that's something
that's pretty important as I say there's
you know there's probably a whole lot of
collinearity among all these these
specific things here so we have some
real serious work to do in unpacking all
that but I just wanna give you a sense
that some of the things we're measuring
are at least correlated in a significant
way with with with a simple outcome
measure about these perceived success by
project participants based on our
initial experience we created wizard 2
point 0 which was announced a little
less than a year ago at the science of
team science conference in Chicago it
kind of rolled it out there it's we
completely rewrote it on a new modular a
platform is written in limesurvey if
you're familiar with added said it's an
open source of survey engine and we
wrote it in a modular way to make it
much easier
Taylor questions and so on and to go
beyond just team size we want to be a
look at collaboration and other kinds of
areas and we've you know drop some
questions we find some questions and so
on fine tune our report generation if
you're interested in the wizard we have
a website Hana the ICS uci.edu / wizard
with some background information about
the project and what what it's all about
and if you are interested in using it
there's a process there for applying
what we do is we have you fill out a
form that says something about your
project and its characteristics and so
on to see if it fits the way the the
presuppositions built into the wizard if
it is then we set up site and ask for a
list of people's emails and we send out
an email inviting them then to come in
and and take the wizard and we actually
often have the project leadership send
out the invitation because I thought in
many cases more persuasive fact for the
ICTs one at the UCI Medical Center where
she had the Dean of the Medical School
send out the invitation that kind of got
people's attention and we we typically
do is have the wizard available for like
two or three weeks and during that time
we'll send out a room one or two
reminders about it and if something
special comes up we've had cases like I
know one case where some big deadline
happened to come close at the end of our
wizard period so we expanded the time
period to give more people a chance to
respondents all weekend we can be
interactive that way so each person gets
an individual report they say we put
together a group report based on all the
individual responses and we think of
this is kind of a win-win situation
because you get some feedback from
information and of course we get a lot
of data which is our business is about
anyway it's the URL for the wizard and
that's the story on the wizard and
collaboration
it's time for a few questions yeah I'll
ask an applied question if I may many of
our departmental courses require small
short-term projects that will that will
last a quarter what recommendations
which would you have for both technology
and for running the collaboration during
that time period it's a really good
question Judy teaches a lot of classes
just exactly like that we have a senior
capstone project where students at such
a year-long project course for our
seniors and informatics and she also
teaches a project management course we
thought it just like an hour ago which
he puts kids into teens they do a term
project and she says I mean and we've
been we've been using google docs
heavily or Google Apps so these docs and
other Google tools google calendar and
so on with some issues but she says that
she actually does a lot of instruction
about team building ought to be an
effective team because at least seniors
at UC Irvine it doesn't need to be a
natural concept to them and she says my
job is as a much social worker and
counselor as it is you know academic
instructor she she actually think he's
like you've written down some of the
things that she has to do to make this
kind of work effectively so I could if
you drop me a note I could probably
afford you or her information because I
think she has had a lot of experience
with this now both admission that now
adore vine and there are some things
about it's a struggle from that is
beginning to work well she is a lot of
insight into that thank you appreciate
that sure yeah so one of the reasons
nothing else early not the only region
because I think that yeah i mean you
listed a lot of good reasons for doing
remote collaboration but one of the
reasons is my experience people do
remote collaborations because they want
to save money on labor and they want to
outsource it the places that are cheaper
and one of the things that is often not
doesn't seem to be taken into
consideration is you know the the x
over header the extra effort in making
those collaborations successful as
opposed to with all the people were
co-located do you have any kind of
estimate of what that overhead or extra
effort would be so that one could make a
reasoned you know estimate of if there
really was going to be any savings or
you know if the project was likely to be
successful because they were willing to
put in that extra well you you fight a
really interesting issue because
sometimes when people are doing the
accounting they don't count like their
time like especially a project leader
you know who might might have all kinds
of headaches because they have to manage
some group in you know China or India or
wherever you know a lot of issues
someone that doesn't appear in their NSF
budget so it doesn't kind of get counted
but he actually really did you know
accurate cost accounting I think you'd
find it might either be a wash or more
expensive isn't it a guy from Stanford
um Steve barley just gave a talk at UCI
this all and he's a lot of work with
General Motors and they had outsourced
and for cost reasons had outsourced a
lot of their engineering design to India
and one of the things they found was
that young people in India don't have
cars and so they don't know what cars
look like or how they work and 11
designer had designed half of a car and
then just said well I can make the whole
car by just do you know making a mirror
image of that well the car had two
steering wheels to gas tank and things
and so on because they didn't know what
a car was so you know they were really
smart engineers but they missed some
very practical everyday knowledge to do
this task right so you know Jim they
spent a lot of money than fixing all
this kind of stuff that's kind of a
concrete example of the problem they're
talking about but I think it is really
and that's what I think you'd want to
have if we made any kind of big
commitment along with like if I want to
try something out on a small scale to
get some sense of how big those issues
are I think they are there
I know some very successful
collaborations some colleague at Irvine
who works very closely with a group at
national university of singapore and
they work together for i don't know at
least half a decade if not longer and it
seems to go very well he does spend a
lot of time there they probably spend
three or four months a year in singapore
but a lot of the work is done when
they're not together and they figured it
all out but you know he's there's a huge
history of investment to make it work
smoothly there's a huge variance I mean
yeah well I say also probably turns a
lot on the area some areas have
knowledge is easy to export some
engineering areas for example and some
areas have a really difficult any
difficult to export relevant expertise
also the sort of level of quality or
level of work that is acceptable I don't
11 company I have previous experience
with the people are probably talking
about some of the friends I have that
are still working there say that what is
accepted and shipped is of lower quality
than what they used to don't find
required and part of that is because of
this remote collaboration talk to boeing
or airbus about that they've had a lot
of experience with that one of the
another thing we've been looking at is
that i mentioned his briefing that Julia
Haynes working on this Pacific Rim
collaboration thing and one of the very
surprising things she found she's been
an internet Google a couple times she's
kind of an inside Google or by now and
she she looked at and I did some of this
work with her people who come from China
and India and work for Google either
still in Beijing or still in bangalore
or now in Mountain View and well it
turns out the people in mountain view
are the most unhappy because they're put
into a new culture and all kinds of
expectations about
that don't fit their experience whereas
the people and so they're the way Julia
puts it is people in bangalore working
with google they can be like google for
brief periods of time like when they're
doing a video conference or something
like that but the rest of the time
they're living in their home culture
whereas when you move you're expected to
do everything in that new culture and
that's much more difficult and it's
pretty difficult about some of the
informal social things and the google
has very odd culture of peer evaluation
that your your evaluations then but not
by your manageable by your peers well
that's quite alien to a lot of asians oh
I learned some Americans find a pretty
alien to man so they're all kinds of
things about how Google runs that kind
of make it hard for people who come who
move who are transplanted as julia calls
it and that's all the more surprising
because google is notorious for hiring
certain kinds of people with a certain
profile of characteristics you know
engineers essentially most of them with
very strong technical backgrounds and so
on and in fact you know if you look at
the technical parts of their work it
works pretty well we start looking at
the social organizational parts how they
fit in how they're viewed by their
colleagues and so on all kinds of red
flags go up so a lot of tricky issues
it's the questions and the mean
technically we give Gary handed thank
you for coming